Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. Hello and welcome to The Rest Is History. Now, yesterday, if you were listening, you will know that we did a walk around Rome and London and we thought it would be fun to have a London-themed week, so we'll be doing another walk later in the week, or ratherlland will be dragging me on another in your bleeding shoes in in yeah in a pair of new shoes inappropriate footwear like the kaiser i was like the kaiser cows wearing inappropriate footwear but we'll come to that in due course so yesterday we're in
感谢您收听《历史的余味》（The Rest Is History）。如需收听每周的额外剧集、享受无广告收听体验、抢先观看系列节目并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。大家好，欢迎收听《历史的余味》。昨天，如果您听了节目，就会知道我们漫步了罗马和伦敦，我们觉得举办一个“伦敦主题周”会很有趣，所以本周晚些时候我们还会再进行一次漫步，或者更确切地说，是威廉会拖着我再走一次，穿着你那双该死的鞋子……是的，穿着一双新鞋，鞋子很不合适，就像凯撒一样，我当时就像凯撒一样穿着不合适的鞋子，但我们稍后再谈这个，所以昨天我们在
roman london and what we're going to do in the build-up to the next war is each day we're going to release a podcast of which this is one, concentrating on a different aspect of London life. So people, places, and moments. And so what we're doing today is we've each chosen a place, haven't we, Tom? We have. That's redolent of a particular era in London's history. Yeah. But you want to talk about a walk, don't you? So the place I have chosen is the only place in London to which I have gone on pilgrimage. And I can tell you the exact date on which I did it. It was the 20th of March last year. This isn't as sentence you often hear. And I remember it because 20th of March, of course, as you will remember, Dominic, is St. Cuthbert's Day, a day that I would normally celebrate by meeting up with Jonathan Wilson and other such people from the northeast and toasting the great saint.
罗马时期的伦敦。在下一次战争爆发前的这段时间里，我们每天都会发布一期播客，本期就是其中之一，重点关注伦敦生活的不同方面。也就是人物、地点和时刻。所以我们今天要做的是，我们每个人都选了一个地方，对吧，汤姆？是的。那个地方让人联想到伦敦历史上的某个特定时代。是的。但你想谈谈漫步，对吧？所以我选择的地方是我在伦敦唯一进行过朝圣的地方。我可以告诉你我去的确切日期。那是去年的3月20日。这可不是你常听到的句子。我记得很清楚，因为3月20日，多米尼克，正如你所记得的，是圣卡斯伯特纪念日（St. Cuthbert's Day），通常我会通过与乔纳森·威尔逊（Jonathan Wilson）和来自东北部的其他人会面，并向这位伟大的圣人敬酒来庆祝这一天。
I couldn't do that. We were under lockdown. So I thought, well, I should I should do something Anglo-Saxon. And so. I went for a very, very long walk, so I went all across South London, so out into Brixton, where I live, or Beorted Seegers Stone, as it was known back in the Anglo-Saxon times, through Peckham, the homestead by the River Peck. I got to Greenwich and then to Woolwich. And the Wych is a wych. It's a kind of great trading emporium. So the green trading emporium and a trading emporium that deals in wool.
我没法那样做。我们当时处于封锁状态。所以我心想，好吧，我应该做点盎格鲁-撒克逊风格的事情。于是，我进行了一次非常非常漫长的步行，我走遍了整个南伦敦，去了我居住的布里克斯顿（Brixton），或者用盎格鲁-撒克逊时代的称呼叫“Beorted Seegers Stone”，穿过佩克汉姆（Peckham），即佩克河畔的家园。我到了格林威治，然后去了伍尔维奇（Woolwich）。“Wych”是一个“wych”。它是一种大型贸易中心。所以是绿色贸易中心，一个经营羊毛的贸易中心。
And at Woolwich, I got the ferry and I went up north and I arrived at Barking which I suppose isn't I mean it's not kind of famous today as a place of pilgrimage but this was the place that I'd come to. Yeah it's not a place you often walk to. It's a very ancient place so it's named in a charter of 735 as Berwick Kingdom, which apparently means either settlement of the descendants of Berwicka or people who live among birch trees. I think I prefer the second. So, Tom, just for people who don't know, tell us where Barking is. Because, I mean, you're doing that London thing. I'm assuming that, I mean, most people don't care about London at all, Tom.
在伍尔维奇，我坐了渡轮去了北边，到达了巴金（Barking），我想这地方……我的意思是，它今天作为朝圣地并不出名，但这确实是我要去的地方。是的，这不是一个你常会步行前往的地方。这是一个非常古老的地方，在735年的一份宪章中被称为“Berwick Kingdom”，这显然意味着“Berwicka后裔的定居点”或者“住在桦树林中的人们”。我想我更喜欢后者。那么，汤姆，为了让不知道的人了解，告诉我们巴金在哪里。因为，我的意思是，你正在做那种“伦敦式”的事情。我假设，我的意思是，大多数人根本不在乎伦敦，汤姆。
So explain to us. So I've gone along South London. I've followed the line of the Thames. Woolwich, there's a ferry. I've got the ferry over to North London. Across the Thames. Across the Thames. And I'm now in East London.
所以给我们解释一下。所以我沿着南伦敦走。我沿着泰晤士河的路线走。伍尔维奇，那里有渡轮。我坐渡轮到了北伦敦。穿过泰晤士河。穿过泰晤士河。我现在在东伦敦。
So quite a long way. I should think about seven or eight miles east of the city of London. Okay. OK, so. So back in. Back in the sixth, back in the seventh century, this was a fair way out from London, the ruins of Roman London. Roman London has been abandoned, but London is a place of interest to the Christian missionaries who have arrived in Kent, sent by Pope Gregory the Great, so Augustine, leading this missionary campaign to convert the Anglo-Saxons to Christianity. And Gregory's plan is that there will be archbishops in London and in York, because in Roman times, these were the centres of colonial administration. But they've come to Kent. Kent has offered a kind of, you know, a welcome. London is much more menacing place. It's a kind of,
所以路程相当远。我想大概在伦敦城以东七八英里的地方。好的。好吧，那么。回到六世纪，回到七世纪，这里离伦敦、离罗马伦敦的废墟还很远。罗马伦敦已经被废弃了，但伦敦是抵达肯特郡的基督教传教士们感兴趣的地方，他们是由教皇格列高利大帝派遣的，所以奥古斯丁领导了这场将盎格鲁-撒克逊人皈依基督教的传教运动。格列高利的计划是，在伦敦和约克设立大主教，因为在罗马时代，这些是殖民行政中心。但他们来到了肯特。肯特提供了一种，你知道的，欢迎。伦敦是一个更具威胁性的地方。它是一种，
it's the Badlands. So that's why Augustine ends up becoming the Archbishop of Canterbury rather than of London, because London is too dangerous for him to settle. Too dangerous, why? Inhabited by stray dogs, bandits, ne'er-do-wells, rather like today. Yes, but also under the thumb of kings who have not yet embraced Christianity. So it's dangerous on the personal level. London is a place you don't really want to visit. Because it's ruined, isn't it? Yeah, and ruins provide hideouts for kind of bandits
它是“荒地”（Badlands）。所以这就是为什么奥古斯丁最终成为了坎特伯雷大主教，而不是伦敦大主教，因为伦敦对他来说太危险了，无法定居。太危险了，为什么？住着流浪狗、强盗、无赖，就像今天一样。是的，而且还处于尚未皈依基督教的国王们的控制之下。所以从个人层面来说很危险。伦敦是一个你真的不想去的地方。因为它是一片废墟，不是吗？是的，废墟为强盗提供了藏身之处
and all kinds of people you wouldn't want to mix with. So it's a dangerous place. But there's still the ambition to get a bishop into London because it's a Roman city. And there's a feeling that a Roman city should have a bishop. So you get this guy called Meletus, who is the first bishop of London. He goes in there. He tries to set up shop. He gets chased out.
以及各种你不想与之混在一起的人。所以这是一个危险的地方。但人们仍然有让一位主教进入伦敦的野心，因为它是一座罗马城市。人们觉得罗马城市应该有一位主教。所以你有了这个叫梅利图斯（Meletus）的人，他是第一任伦敦主教。他去了那里。他试图在那里立足。但他被赶了出来。
And he flees not only London, but England itself. He basically scarpers back to Gaul. So, again, London is left without a bishop. But meanwhile, in Kent, more and more people are becoming Christian. The ruling family in particular are becoming Christian. And you get this guy called Urquhart, who's probably of Kentish Royal descent, who gets appointed Bishop of London, have another crack at it. And he goes back and he is able to establish the church in London sufficiently that Urquhald is the first in the continuous line of bishops that runs right the way up to the present day. So there's still a Bishop of London now. Bishop of London stands in a line of descent from Erkenwald.
他不仅逃离了伦敦，甚至逃离了英格兰。他基本上逃回了高卢。所以，伦敦再次没有了主教。但与此同时，在肯特，越来越多的人成为了基督徒。尤其是统治家族成为了基督徒。然后你有了这个叫厄肯瓦尔德（Erkenwald）的人，他可能出身于肯特王室，他被任命为伦敦主教，再试一次。他回去了，并且成功地在伦敦建立了教会，以至于厄肯瓦尔德成为了从那时起一直延续到今天的主教世系中的第一人。所以现在仍然有一位伦敦主教。伦敦主教的传承可以追溯到厄肯瓦尔德。
Now, Erkenwald, before he becomes Bishop of London, has set up two abbeys on the outskirts of London, one at Chertsey, which is southwest of London, andes at Barking will become one of the great, great centres of scholarship and specifically a female scholarship. Because the person who is put in charge of the abbey is Erkenwald's sister, Ethelberg. Ethelberg? Ethelberg. Okay. Or Ethelberger, if you fancy her. Let's go with Ethelberger. That. Or Ethelberger, if you fancy her. Let's go with Ethelberger. That's slightly easier to say.
现在，厄肯瓦尔德在成为伦敦主教之前，在伦敦郊外建立了两个修道院，一个在切特西（Chertsey），在伦敦西南部，而巴金将成为学术，特别是女性学术的伟大中心之一。因为被任命负责修道院的人是厄肯瓦尔德的妹妹，埃塞尔伯格（Ethelberg）。埃塞尔伯格？埃塞尔伯格。好的。或者如果你喜欢的话，叫埃塞尔伯格（Ethelberger）。我们叫她埃塞尔伯格吧。那个。或者如果你喜欢的话，叫埃塞尔伯格。这稍微好说一点。
And she is a saintly figure, a virgin, a nun, but also a great scholar. And she establishes this idea that Barking should be a place not just for prayer, but of scholarship, and specifically of female scholarship. So I never had Barking down as a sort of blue stocking stronghold. Absolutely. But this is what it was. And so when she's a figure of transcendent holiness, when she dies, a nun in Barking sees her drawn up to heaven, carried on golden chains.
她是一位圣洁的人物，一位处女，一位修女，但也是一位伟大的学者。她确立了这样一个理念：巴金不仅应该是祈祷的地方，也应该是学术，特别是女性学术的地方。所以我从来没把巴金看作是某种“蓝袜女”（知识女性）的大本营。绝对是。但事实就是这样。所以当她成为一位具有超凡神圣性的人物时，当她去世时，巴金的一位修女看到她被金链子拉上天堂。
So she's been taken up and she becomes a saint. And from that point on, basically, the abbess of Barking is the kind of the top abbess in the whole of England. And that's that's a status that she she has right the way through the Middle Ages. There's a wonderful there's a wonderful scholar of this period called Eleanor Parker, who's at Oxford. And she has a blog under the name of's at Oxford. And she has a blog under the name of Clark of Oxford. And she's on Twitter as well. I cannot recommend it highly enough. It's absolutely one of my favourite Twitter accounts, one of my favourite blogs. And she kind of goes through the Anglo-Saxon liturgical year, which may sound a bit boring, but it really isn't because
所以她被带走了，并成为了一位圣人。从那时起，基本上，巴金的女院长就是整个英格兰地位最高的女院长。这种地位一直持续到整个中世纪。有一位研究这一时期的出色学者叫埃莉诺·帕克（Eleanor Parker），她在牛津大学。她以“牛津书记员”（Clark of Oxford）的名义写博客。她在推特上也有账号。我强烈推荐。这绝对是我最喜欢的推特账号之一，也是我最喜欢的博客之一。她会梳理盎格鲁-撒克逊的礼仪年，这听起来可能有点无聊，但实际上并非如此，因为
it's full of kind of all the fantastic stories of what the saints get up to, the miracles, mad Vikings, all this kind of thing. Eleanor described barking abbey in in a post she did on it as perhaps the longest lived institutional center of literary culture for women in british history which is a kind of you know an amazing thing but people make more of it tom they should make more of it well because the reformation intervenes but before the reformation you know they're this incredible um tradition that that Eleanor describes and a whole kind of succession of of remarkable women so in the reign of Edgar the peaceable um Anglo-Saxon king of the 10th century called peaceable not because he was a hippie but because he maintained the peace by hanging anyone who gave him any problems. Yeah. Strong leadership for a stable prison.
它充满了圣徒们所做的各种奇妙故事、奇迹、疯狂的维京人等等。埃莉诺在关于巴金修道院的一篇文章中将其描述为“英国历史上存在时间最长的女性文学文化机构中心”，这真是一件了不起的事情，但人们应该更多地谈论它，汤姆，他们应该更多地谈论它。好吧，因为宗教改革介入了，但在宗教改革之前，你知道，有埃莉诺所描述的这种令人难以置信的传统，以及一连串非凡的女性。所以在10世纪盎格鲁-撒克逊国王“和平者”埃德加（Edgar the Peaceable）的统治时期，之所以叫“和平者”，不是因为他是嬉皮士，而是因为他通过绞死任何给他制造麻烦的人来维持和平。是的。为了稳定统治的强力领导。
Yeah. Yeah. Law and order. So Edgar the Peaceable fancied this Anglo-Saxon lady called Wolfhilda, who had grown up in Wilton, which is just outside Salisbury. So very local to me. And Edgar the Peaceable really, really fancied her. But Wolfhilda was obviously very holy, wanted to go off and devote herself to God. So had no time for the advances of Edgar the Peaceful. And Edgar was he was so bad that he sent a message to Wolfhilda saying that her aunt was ill. So Wolfhilda, obviously, you know, very anxious about this, comes rushing to her aunt, goes into her aunt's bedroom. But is Edgar the Peaceful there?
是的。是的。法律与秩序。所以“和平者”埃德加看上了这位叫沃尔菲尔达（Wolfhilda）的盎格鲁-撒克逊女士，她在威尔顿（Wilton）长大，就在索尔兹伯里（Salisbury）外面。所以对我来说非常本地。埃德加确实非常看上她。但沃尔菲尔达显然非常神圣，想离开并投身于上帝。所以没时间理会埃德加的追求。埃德加太坏了，他给沃尔菲尔达传话，说她姑姑病了。所以沃尔菲尔达显然非常担心，急忙赶到她姑姑那里，走进她姑姑的卧室。但“和平者”埃德加在那里吗？
Wow. It's not the aunt at all. That's not very peaceful at all, is it? And so Wolfhilda gives him a slap, runs off, and escapes by going down the drains, apparently. That's very carry- on, isn't it? Yeah, it's very. It is. Yeah, it's carry on Anglo-Saxon nunnery. Anyway, so Wilfelder protects her chastity and virtue and ends up as a very particularly saintly abbess of Barking.
哇。根本不是姑姑。这可一点也不“和平”，对吧？于是沃尔菲尔达给了他一巴掌，跑开了，显然是通过下水道逃脱的。这非常像《随身携带》（Carry On）系列电影，不是吗？是的，非常像。确实。是的，这是《随身携带之盎格鲁-撒克逊修女院》。总之，沃尔菲尔达保护了自己的贞洁和美德，最终成为了一位非常圣洁的巴金女院长。
Well, that's good. So that's good. Other famous people who became, who were barking. So Thomas Beckett's sister, Mary, Mary Beckett. She's not technically famous, but I mean, he's famous. Yeah. She's got famous relative. She's a top sister.
好吧，那很好。那么还有哪些名人成为了巴金修道院的人？托马斯·贝克特（Thomas Beckett）的妹妹，玛丽·贝克特（Mary Beckett）。她技术上不算出名，但我的意思是，他很出名。是的。她有个出名的亲戚。她是个顶级的妹妹。
She's a top sister. So she gets it after her brother's been killed. It's a kind of mark of penance. So basically Henry II, yeah, groveling gives her says be abes forgive me and another another relative of a famous medieval figure um Elizabeth Chaucer who is the daughter of Geoffrey Chaucer she's a nun there yeah again not technically famous but you're getting a sense that um this is this is the go-to place this is this is the place for kind of top nuns um which is which is why it's such a shit you know there are times where i really hate the
她是个顶级的妹妹。她在她哥哥被杀后得到了这个职位。这是一种忏悔的标志。所以基本上亨利二世，是的，卑躬屈膝地给她说“做女院长吧，原谅我”。还有另一位中世纪名人的亲戚，杰弗里·乔叟（Geoffrey Chaucer）的女儿伊丽莎白·乔叟（Elizabeth Chaucer），她是那里的修女。是的，同样技术上不算出名，但你开始感觉到，这是一个首选之地，这是顶级修女们去的地方，这就是为什么它如此……你知道，有时候我真的很讨厌
reformation and the thought of what happens to barking abbey is one of them um so this great ancient historic center of learning gets closed down it all gets flogged off um and all that basically you know it all gets demolished and basically all that remains is um one of the three gateways it's it's called the curfew tower so you can still see it there in the middle of barking but but nothing nothing else remains i had you down this is we've done 200 odd podcasts and you've never really come out but i've always suspected that you were unsound about the reformformation. No, well, I'd read so much about Barking Abbey. Yeah.
宗教改革，想到巴金修道院发生的事情就是其中之一。所以这个伟大的古老历史学习中心被关闭了，一切都被变卖了，基本上一切都被拆毁了，剩下的基本上只有三个门楼之一。它被称为“宵禁塔”（Curfew Tower），所以你仍然可以在巴金的中心看到它，但除此之外什么都没剩下。我一直认为，我们做了200多期播客，你从来没有真正表态，但我一直怀疑你对宗教改革的看法是不稳固的。不，好吧，我读过很多关于巴金修道院的书。是的。
And, you know, what an amazing centre. And to go there and to see, you know, there's absolutely nothing there. It was very, very sad. However, I then continued my pilgrimage, Dominic. When you say pilgrimage, I mean, were you carrying a cross? No, but I was, you know, I wanted to see it but i was you know i wanted to see it it was a place i wanted to see i walked there but then i wanted to continue the pilgrimage because the story is not completely over not every trace of barking has gone oh this is exciting yeah so i then walked um westwards so through the east end yeah and i got to the
而且，你知道，这是一个多么了不起的中心。去那里看到，你知道，那里什么都没有。这非常非常令人难过。然而，我随后继续了我的朝圣之旅，多米尼克。当你说是朝圣时，我的意思是，你背着十字架吗？不，但我当时，你知道，我想看看它，但这是一个我想看的地方。我走到了那里，但我还想继续朝圣，因为故事还没有完全结束，巴金的每一丝痕迹都没有消失。哦，这太令人兴奋了。是的，所以我随后向西走，穿过东区，是的，我到了
tower of london god this is quite a walk, Tom. Yeah, it's a massive walk. It was absolutely massive. It was quite hot. And I, you know, and it was the lockdown. So it was shut. So and I'd run out of water. So I was getting quite dehydrated. Anyway, I arrived by the Tower of London. There is a church called All Hallows by the Tower. And it's a very ancient church, but it looks quite modern. And that's not because it got burnt down in the fire of London, but because it got blown up by gunpowder in 1650. So, all right.
伦敦塔。天哪，这真是段漫长的路，汤姆。是的，这是一次巨大的步行。绝对是巨大的。天气很热。而且，你知道，当时是封锁期间。所以它关门了。而且我的水喝完了。所以我开始变得相当脱水。总之，我到达了伦敦塔。那里有一座教堂叫“塔楼诸圣堂”（All Hallows by the Tower）。它是一座非常古老的教堂，但看起来很现代。那不是因为它在伦敦大火中被烧毁，而是因为它在1650年被火药炸毁了。所以，好吧。
So 16 years. Yeah. So it was it was a kind of storehouse during the Civil War. Yeah. And then it got very, very badly bombed in the Blitz. And this bombing revealed something really, really startling, which is an Anglo-Saxon doorway made out of Roman tiles. And this is basically the only fragment of Anglo-Saxon architecture that you'll find anywhere in London.
所以16年。是的。所以它在内战期间是一个仓库。是的。然后它在闪电战中被炸得非常非常严重。这次轰炸揭示了一些非常非常令人震惊的事情，那就是一个用罗马瓷砖制成的盎格鲁-撒克逊门道。这基本上是你在伦敦任何地方能找到的唯一的盎格鲁-撒克逊建筑碎片。
And it dates right the way back to the time of the founding of Barking Abbey. And the reason, the link with Barking Abbey is that in the Middle Ages, it was this church, Orhalis by the Tower, was known as Birking Church. And so the presumption is that it was founded by Erkenwald and given to Barking Abbey. And as such, it's a kind of, you know, it's a precious living link to the traditions of Barking Abbey. And in fact, so it's, you know, it joins the Anglo-Sax the traditions of Barking Abbey um and in fact so it's you know it joins the Anglo-Saxon traditions of Christianity to the Roman history of London because the the brickwork is there so very very very moving there are um there's a stained glass window that um name checks
它的历史可以追溯到巴金修道院建立的时候。而且，与巴金修道院的联系在于，在中世纪，这座教堂，塔楼诸圣堂，被称为“巴金教堂”（Birking Church）。所以推测它是由厄肯瓦尔德建立并赠予巴金修道院的。因此，它是一种珍贵的、活生生的、与巴金修道院传统相连的纽带。事实上，它将盎格鲁-撒克逊的基督教传统与伦敦的罗马历史连接了起来，因为砖砌结构就在那里，所以非常非常感人。那里有一扇彩色玻璃窗，上面提到了
Barking Abbey there's an icon of Saint Ethelberger um in in all hallows and also you you may remember there's a there's a very small church also in the city dedicated to saint ethelberger which survived both the great fire and the blitz but then got blown up by the ira oh yeah you remember that i do i think 1993 yeah part of that kind of massive bombing campaign in the city i mean they weren't targeting saint in Athelberger, but it was collateral damage. And I got welcomed to All Hallows by the vicar who gave me a wonderful welcome. Did he know you were coming? She. She?
巴金修道院。在塔楼诸圣堂里有一幅圣埃塞尔伯格的圣像。而且你可能还记得，在伦敦城里还有一座非常小的教堂，专门供奉圣埃塞尔伯格，它在大火和闪电战中都幸存了下来，但后来被爱尔兰共和军（IRA）炸毁了。哦，是的，你记得那个。我记得，我想是1993年。那是伦敦大规模爆炸行动的一部分。我的意思是，他们并不是针对圣埃塞尔伯格，但那是附带损害。我在塔楼诸圣堂受到了牧师的欢迎，她给了我非常热情的欢迎。她知道你要来吗？她。她？
Yeah. So she's in the tradition of St. Athelberger. Right. She did. I phoned ahead and she gave me a cup of tea, which was one of the best cups of tea I've had. Were you not breaking lockdown regulations there, Tom? No, I think it was okay. I think it was okay. That's what he's saying for the benefit of the podcast. Dominic Cummings of history, they'd call him.
是的。所以她继承了圣埃塞尔伯格的传统。对。她确实。我提前打了电话，她给了我一杯茶，那是我喝过的最好的茶之一。汤姆，你在那里没有违反封锁规定吗？不，我想没问题。我想没问题。那是他为了播客的利益而说的。历史界的“多米尼克·卡明斯”（Dominic Cummings），他们会这样称呼他。
Yeah, maybe I've given it all away there. So two questions that I think the listeners will want to know. One, how did the walk conclude? Oh, so I carried on through the city. I went to see the docks that King Alfred built, only surviving portion of Anglo section architecture on the banks of the Thames. I went to Westminster Abbey, of course, you know, built by Edward the Confessor. Yeah. And then I walked back to Brixton. Crikey, that is a walk, Tom.
是的，也许我刚才把一切都泄露了。所以我想听众们会想知道两个问题。第一，这次步行是如何结束的？哦，我继续穿过伦敦城。我去看阿尔弗雷德大帝建造的码头，那是泰晤士河畔仅存的盎格鲁-撒克逊建筑部分。我去了威斯敏斯特教堂，当然，你知道，那是忏悔者爱德华建造的。是的。然后我走回了布里克斯顿。天哪，那真是一次漫步，汤姆。
It was a long walk. It was a very long walk. Yeah. The other question, though, is, so if listeners are inspired by your talk of top nuns to go and visit Barking Abbey for themselves, what will they see? They will see this single tower, the curfew tower, one of the three gateways that led into the abbey,
那是一次漫长的步行。那是一次非常漫长的步行。是的。不过另一个问题是，如果听众们被你关于“顶级修女”的谈话所激励，想要亲自去参观巴金修道院，他们会看到什么？他们会看到这座孤零零的塔，宵禁塔，通往修道院的三个门楼之一，
and that's all that remains. And is it sort of surrounded by, I don't know, I can't imagine, what is there in Barking? Is it surrounded by sandwich shops? No, there's a very nice green open space um there's a church next to it um and then you've got uh barking high street lots of street markets all that kind of thing well it's it's it's uh it's a good place it's not it doesn't have the aura of a great center of female scholarship let's put it like that so what the barking tourist board will make of your description who knows
这就是剩下的全部了。它是被什么包围的，我不知道，我无法想象，巴金有什么？它是被三明治店包围的吗？不，那里有一个非常好的绿色开放空间，旁边有一座教堂，然后你有巴金商业街，有很多街头市场等等。好吧，这是一个好地方，它没有那种伟大女性学术中心的光环，我们这么说吧。所以巴金旅游局会对你的描述作何感想，谁知道呢。
because you kind of you gave with one hand and took away with the other i felt that but um everybody should go and check the tower out for themselves i think well i think it's i think it's one of those places that you need to know what stood there or else it won't particularly hit you as anything worth visiting like 99 of archaeological sites in other words well definitely like anglo-saxon london of you know, as I say, there's basically only this doorway. I mean, that's all that's physically preserved of it. Yeah. So if you want to go in search of Anglo-Saxon London, you know, there's very little to see.
因为你给了一只手，又拿走了另一只手，我感觉到了。但是，每个人都应该亲自去看看那座塔。我想，好吧，我认为这是那种你需要知道那里曾经矗立着什么的地方，否则它不会让你觉得有什么值得一游的，换句话说，就像99%的考古遗址一样。好吧，绝对像盎格鲁-撒克逊伦敦，正如我所说，基本上只有这个门道。我的意思是，这就是它物理上保存下来的全部。是的。所以如果你想去寻找盎格鲁-撒克逊伦敦，你知道，几乎没什么可看的。
You really need to take your imagination with you. Yeah. Okay. It's like that thing that members of my household have been known to say when I've suggested visits to historic sites where they've said, is it just a heap of stones? Yeah, because you're barking at me, it's not even a heap of stones. There's literally nothing. So it's even more exciting.
你真的需要带上你的想象力。是的。好的。这就像我家里人有时会说的那样，当我建议参观历史遗址时，他们会说：“那只是一堆石头吗？”是的，因为对于巴金修道院来说，它甚至连一堆石头都不是。真的什么都没有。所以它更令人兴奋。
But Dominic, that's why I went on my own. Yeah. I mean, I knew better than to drag Sadie along for that. Yes. Look, darling, we've walked 20 miles and here it is. The single best image of you, Tom, is that image of you having dragged your family... It's on the internet somewhere, isn't it? Because you tweeted it.
但是多米尼克，这就是为什么我一个人去。是的。我的意思是，我比这更清楚，不会拖着萨迪（Sadie）去那种地方。是的。看，亲爱的，我们走了20英里，这就是它。关于你，汤姆，最好的形象就是你拖着家人……它在互联网上的某个地方，对吧？因为你发了推特。
Of you having dragged your family to Hadrian's Wall. Yes. And it's pouring with rain. They're clearly... Years ago, on a summer holiday, two small girls standing there in their anoraks. Yeah, in the outskirts of Newcastle. Looking so miserable in a garage forecourt or something.
你拖着家人去了哈德良长城。是的。而且当时下着倾盆大雨。他们显然……多年前，在一个暑假，两个小女孩穿着雨衣站在那里。是的，在纽卡斯尔郊外。在车库前院之类的东西里看起来很痛苦。
Happy days. Brilliant. So we should take a break, I think. And when we return, let us, we'll be catapulted forward into the 1950s. There will be drinks and the mood will be very different from the female scholarship of Barking Abbey.
快乐的日子。太棒了。我想我们应该休息一下。当我们回来时，我们将被弹射到1950年代。会有饮料，气氛将与巴金修道院的女性学术氛围截然不同。
So we'll see you after the break. Brilliant. Bye-bye. I'm Marina Hyde and I'm Richard Osman and together we host The Rest Is Entertainment it's your weekly fix of entertainment news reviews splash of showbiz gossip and on our Q&A we pull back the curtain
所以休息后见。太棒了。再见。我是玛丽娜·海德（Marina Hyde），我是理查德·奥斯曼（Richard Osman），我们共同主持《娱乐的余味》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。这是您每周的娱乐新闻、评论、一点点演艺圈八卦的固定节目，在我们的问答环节中，我们拉开帷幕
on entertainment and we tell you how it all works we have just launched our members club if you want ad free listening bonus episodes and early access to live tickets head to
揭示娱乐业的内幕，并告诉您它是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部，如果您想要无广告收听、额外剧集和抢先获得现场门票，请前往
therestisentertainment.com that's dot com. That's therestisentertainment dot com. Hello, welcome back to The Rest Is History and welcome back to our London week. All this week we're looking at the history of the British capital and today we are looking at places and in the first
therestisentertainment.com，就是点com。那是 therestisentertainment 点 com。你好，欢迎回到《历史的余味》，欢迎回到我们的伦敦周。整个这一周我们都在审视英国首都的历史，今天我们正在审视地点，在前半部分
half we looked at Barking Abbey, which was my nomination, and Dominic, now time for your nomination, which I think is much more recent, isn't it? It is indeed. So we're in the years after the Second World War in the 1950s. Now, Tom, you said in the first half that the vicar of the church, the All Hallows Church or whatever it is, not that I've forgotten, but... All Hallows Tower. I kind of have forgotten.
我们看了巴金修道院，这是我的提名，多米尼克，现在轮到你的提名了，我想这更近一些，对吧？确实如此。所以我们是在二战后的1950年代。现在，汤姆，你在前半部分说教堂的牧师，塔楼诸圣堂还是什么的，不是我忘了，而是……塔楼诸圣堂。我确实有点忘了。
So she gave you a cup of tea. Yeah. Not a cup of coffee. No, not a cup of coffee, cup of tea. So had you been strolling around London in the years after the Second World War, you would have found lots of places to give you a cup of tea. But coffee might have been more of an issue because, of course, England, London had had a history of coffee houses,
所以她给了你一杯茶。是的。不是咖啡。不，不是咖啡，是茶。所以如果你在二战后的几年里在伦敦漫步，你会发现很多地方可以给你一杯茶。但咖啡可能是一个问题，因为当然，英格兰，伦敦曾经有咖啡馆的历史，
but was very much a kind of tea place, I would say, kind of first half of the 20th century, kind of George Orwell writing essays about how to make the perfect cup of tea and so on. But the 1950s are boom years for coffee, Tom. And why is that? So lots of Italian immigrants moved to Britain in the years after the second world war
但我会说，20世纪上半叶，它更像是一个喝茶的地方，乔治·奥威尔写文章关于如何泡出一杯完美的茶等等。但1950年代是咖啡的繁荣时期，汤姆。为什么会这样？所以二战后有很多意大利移民搬到了英国
uh there's a big demand for labor um italy is a great exporter net sort of net exporter of people and so they're bringing their kind of shiny coffee machines they are bringing shiny coffee machines so the place that a lot of italians i mean italians go all over the country they go to places like bedford um working brickmaking and so on. But they, in London, lots move to Soho. Because Soho has always been, it's a terrible cliche, but it's kind of because of all the melting pot and stuff. Yeah, so Huguenots go there, don't they?
对劳动力有很大的需求，意大利是一个伟大的出口国，某种意义上的净人口出口国，所以他们带来了那种闪亮的咖啡机，他们带来了闪亮的咖啡机。所以很多意大利人去的地方，我的意思是意大利人遍布全国，他们去贝德福德（Bedford）等地，从事制砖工作等等。但是，在伦敦，很多人搬到了苏豪区（Soho）。因为苏豪区一直以来，这是一个糟糕的陈词滥调，但它是因为所有的熔炉等等。是的，所以胡格诺派教徒去了那里，不是吗？
Huguenots, exactly. So if you go to, I mean, Soho, for overseas listeners, it's right in the heart of London. It used to have a kind of seedy reputation, but not really anymore. Sort of very trendy media kind of people. But in the 50s, it was kind of notorious as the red light district, wasn't it? Yes. Kind of vice. I think the 50s, it wasn't quite as seedy as it would become in the sort of 60s, 70s.
胡格诺派教徒，没错。所以如果你去，我的意思是，苏豪区，对于海外听众来说，它就在伦敦的中心。它过去有一种肮脏的名声，但现在真的没有了。那种非常时髦的媒体类人群。但在50年代，它被认为是红灯区，不是吗？是的。那种罪恶。我想50年代，它还没有像60年代、70年代那样肮脏。
So in the 50s, I think, above all, it's cosmopolitan. I mean, it does have that kind of artist exactly i mean of course there are a lot there are you know um prostitutes there are sort of dodgy bars there are all those kinds of things um but i think when people think of soho they think it's going to be full of delicatessens coffee shops all these things so you have lots of coffee bars um around old compton street in particular in soho so there are lots of italian restaurants so they're called things like amalfi and and presto and so on there's a place in frith street called mocha which is supposedly the first
所以在50年代，我认为，最重要的是，它是国际化的。我的意思是，它确实有那种艺术家……没错，我的意思是当然那里有很多妓女，有那种不正经的酒吧，有所有那些东西，但我认为当人们想到苏豪区时，他们认为它会充满熟食店、咖啡店，所有这些东西。所以你在苏豪区，特别是在老康普顿街（Old Compton Street）周围有很多咖啡吧，所以有很多意大利餐馆，它们的名字叫阿马尔菲（Amalfi）和普雷斯托（Presto）等等。在弗里斯街（Frith Street）有一个叫摩卡（Mocha）的地方，据说是英国第一个
place in britain to have an espresso machine so a gadget machine so Dominic, this is the 50s. This is the 50s. London is still very dingy, very kind of smoky, austere. So not a place full of light and colour and vibrant street life. No. So Soho is a kind of a blaze of colour in an otherwise dingy urban landscape? I think that's a tiny bit harsh, but I think there's a bit of truth in that. So Soho is a blaze of, i mean i suppose you would say now people would say now a blaze of diversity to some extent um it's it's less monochrome than much of london uh you can buy foods that you can't get elsewhere you can buy foreign newspapers those kinds of things you
拥有浓缩咖啡机的地方，也就是那种小玩意机器。所以多米尼克，这是50年代。这是50年代。伦敦仍然非常阴暗，非常烟雾缭绕，朴素。所以不是一个充满光线、色彩和充满活力的街头生活的地方。不。所以苏豪区是在一个原本阴暗的城市景观中闪耀的色彩？我觉得这有点苛刻，但我认为其中有一点道理。所以苏豪区是一片闪耀的，我的意思是我想现在人们会说是一片多样性的闪耀，在某种程度上，它比伦敦大部分地区更少单色，你可以买到在其他地方买不到的食物，你可以买到外国报纸等等，所以你
might go there for an italian meal that you might not find you know a few streets away so it's busy and it's exciting um and if you go down to old compton street um in let's say 19 beginning of 1956 and you go to number 59 you can find among the coffee bars, there is a coffee bar there called The Two Eyes. So it's called The Two Eyes. It starts as a kind of sandwich bar stroke coffee bar, and it's opened by some brothers called Irani, who I'm assuming are of Iranian descent. And there are three of them.
可能会去那里吃一顿你在几条街外可能找不到的意大利餐，所以它很忙碌，很令人兴奋。如果你在1956年初去老康普顿街，去59号，你可以在咖啡吧中找到，那里有一家叫“双眼”（The Two Eyes）的咖啡吧。所以它叫“双眼”。它最初是一种三明治吧兼咖啡吧，由一些叫伊拉尼（Irani）的兄弟开设，我假设他们是伊朗裔。他们有三个人。
They're originally going to call it the three eyes. They're one of them. But one of them falls out with the other. So he's booted out, and it's the two eyes. And it's not very successful, actually. There are lots of better coffee bars around and sort of milk bars. Yeah, so what's a milk bar? You just go and drink milk?
他们最初打算叫它“三眼”。他们是其中之一。但其中一个与另一个闹翻了。所以他被踢出去了，就变成了“双眼”。实际上它不是很成功。周围有很多更好的咖啡吧和那种奶吧。是的，那么什么是奶吧？你只是去喝牛奶吗？
Yeah, so a milk bar, basically, I think it's kind of like a coffee bar, but it serves milk. There's very trendy kind of late 50s things. But it's literally just milk? No, I think they have other stuff in milk bars. I've always been slightly puzzled by milk bars. You kind of read it. I think they sort of started in Australia, actually,
是的，所以奶吧，基本上，我想它有点像咖啡吧，但它供应牛奶。这是50年代末非常时髦的东西。但它真的是只有牛奶吗？不，我想奶吧里还有其他东西。我对奶吧一直有点困惑。你读到过它。我想它们实际上是在澳大利亚开始的，
and then came to Britain. And they're very sort of redolent of the late 50s and early 60s. When I used to go to holiday to Wales as a child in the early 80s I remember there was a milk bar in Mahanthlith which I think must have been one of the last remaining milk bars in Britain. Anyway so the Two Eyes is there and it's this sort of slightly failed sandwich bar straight coffee bar so if you went into one of these 50s coffee bars there's a sort of espresso machine clanking behind the
然后来到了英国。它们非常让人联想到50年代末和60年代初。当我小时候在80年代初去威尔士度假时，我记得在马汉莱斯（Machynlleth）有一家奶吧，我想那一定是英国最后剩下的奶吧之一。总之，“双眼”就在那里，它是一种稍微失败的三明治吧兼咖啡吧。所以如果你走进这些50年代的咖啡吧之一，柜台后面有一种浓缩咖啡机在叮当作响，有盆栽植物，有那种时髦的塑料椅子，还有年轻人坐在那里，拿着他们的法国存在主义书籍等等。所以汤姆，你有没有看过一部叫《叛逆者》（The Rebel）的电影，主演是托尼·汉考克（Tony Hancock），这是一种，
counter there are sort of pot plants there are sort of trendy plastic chairs and there's sort of youngsters sitting around with their copies of kind of French existentialist books and so on so Tom have you ever seen there's a film called The rebel with Tony Hancock, which is a sort of,
这是一种嘲讽那种趋势的电影，50年代末那种存在主义的趋势，以及所有那些穿着粗呢大衣的人。没错。没错。人们穿着粗呢大衣，那种垮掉派（beatniks），
it's a sort of, it's a film mocking that sort of trend, the late fifties trend for kind of existentialism and all this kind of people wearing duffel coats. Exactly. Exactly. People wearing duffel coats, sort of beatniks,
英国垮掉派。在这部电影里，我想托尼·汉考克退学了，他想成为一名艺术家什么的。他走进这家咖啡吧，说他想要一杯咖啡。他说：“我想要一杯没有泡沫的咖啡。”柜台后面的女人说：“没有泡沫？他要没有泡沫干什么？”还有一个留着大胡子的意大利人
British beatniks. And in this film, I think Tony Hancock drops out and he wants to become an artist or something. And he goes into this coffee bar and he says he wants a cup of coffee. And he says, I want a cup of coffee with no froth on it. And the woman behind the counter is like, no froth? What's he want no froth for? And there's a man with a massive moustache who's an Italian
说：“我为什么要投资一台昂贵的机器，而他却想要没有泡沫？”等等。总之，“双眼”是这种趋势的失败版本。伊朗人最终把它卖了。他们把它卖给了两个
who says kind of, what did I invest in an expensive machine for when he wants no froth and all this kind of thing. Anyway, so The Two Eyes is a failed version of this. The Iranians eventually sell it. They sell it to two
澳大利亚摔跤手。哇。其中一个，我想是唯一一个名字留下来、广为人知的人，是一个叫保罗·林肯（Paul Lincoln）的家伙，
Australian wrestlers. Wow. One of whom, the one of whom I think is the only one whose name remains, is well known, is a guy called Paul Lincoln
他在摔跤场上以“死亡博士”（Dr. Death）的名字进行交易。所以死亡博士，他们现在有了一家咖啡吧，“双眼”。它同样没用，它有点亏钱，而且你可能太忙于摔跤了，可能吧，是的，没错。我可以喝杯咖啡吗？不，我得去……是的，你得去处理我的斗篷什么的。但拯救了这家酒吧命运的是他们有一个小小的地下室。所以基本上，咖啡店本身，有一个容纳大约20人的房间。而在地下室，他们可以容纳，我不知道，
who traded in the wrestling arena under the name dr death so dr death they've got a coffee bar now the two eyes it's equally useless it sort of hemorrhages money and you may be too busy wrestling probably probably yes exactly can i have a coffee no i've got to go and yeah you've got to go and work on my cape or whatever. But what sort of rescues the fortunes of the bar is they have a tiny basement. So basically, the coffee shop itself, there's a room for about 20 people. And in the basement, they can fit in, I don't know,
100人左右在这个汗流浃背的地窖里。在地窖的尽头，他们有一个用奶箱，那种牛奶瓶箱做的舞台，还有一个麦克风，根据我在网上读到的东西，它说这个麦克风是布尔战争（Boer War）留下的。我不知道，我不相信那可能是真的。我不敢相信他们在那个地窖里有麦克风，这似乎不太可能。这确实似乎不太可能。如果有什么布尔战争中麦克风的历史学家，请告诉我们。如果这个播客里有一些历史学家就好了，你可以告诉我们。总之，他们开始让人在地下室演奏音乐，
100 people or so in this sort of sweaty cellar. And at the end of the cellar, they have a stage made of milk crates kind of milk bottle crates and there's a microphone which according to the thing i read online it says the microphone is left over from the burr war i don't know i'm not convinced that could be true i can't believe they had microphones in cellars in the seems improbable it does seem improbable. If there are any historians of microphones in the
他们找了一个叫“沃利·怀特和毒蛇乐队”（Wally White and the Vipers）的乐队。汤姆，你熟悉他们的作品吗？喜欢他们。所以你可能会嘲笑沃利·怀特和毒蛇乐队，但他们是由一个人制作的，嗯，所以你可能会嘲笑沃利·怀特和毒蛇乐队，
Boer War, let us know. If only there were some historians involved with this podcast, you could tell us. Anyway, so they start having people to play music in the basement
但他们是由一个你肯定听说过的人制作的，叫乔治·马丁（George Martin）。哦，对了，所以他们确实有几首热门歌曲，他们有一些前十名的热门歌曲。现在，沃利·怀特和毒蛇乐队演奏的音乐是“斯基弗尔”（Skiffle）。大多数英国听众可能听说过“斯基弗尔”这个词，我们的大多数海外听众可能没听说过，也不知道它是什么。所以斯基弗尔真的真的很难定义，但我认为纯粹主义者可能会抱怨我的定义，但我会说斯基弗尔是你会在50年代中期到末期的英国找到的那种音乐，它基本上就像是蓝调、民谣、原始摇滚乐的一种非常稀释的版本，非常DIY，而且非常DIY，不是吗？非常DIY。
and they get a band called Wally White and the Vipers. Are you familiar with their work, Tom? Love them. So you may mock Wally White and the Vipers, but they were produced by a man um so you may mock wally white and the vipers
而且DIY，业余精神就是重点。所以这是那些基本上买了廉价吉他、搓衣板之类东西的人，他们作为青少年在卧室里演奏。所以披头士，初学者，斯基弗尔乐队。是的。所以几乎很多这些乐队，60年代很多标志性的乐队开始
but they were produced by a man who you'll definitely heard of called george martin oh right so they actually have a few hits they have some top 10 hits now what the music that the wally white and the vipers are playing is skiffle so most british listeners will probably have heard the word skiffle most of our overseas listeners probably won't and won't know what it is so skiffle is really really hard to define but it's i suppose purists will probably complain about my definition but i would say skiffle is the kind of music that you find in mid to late 50s britain and it's basically like a very diluted version of blues of folk kind of proto rock and roll very diy And very DIY, isn't it? Very DIY.
或者作为斯基弗尔乐队，或者在他们14或15岁时开始演奏斯基弗尔，只是在卧室里用那些糟糕的吉他以一种非常轻快、快乐的方式演奏几乎是民谣蓝调之类的音乐。所以这就是沃利·怀特和毒蛇乐队在做的事情。而且他们非常成功，我想到了1957年左右，“双眼”外面开始排队，然后人们开始注意到斯基弗尔。所以56、57年的英国是一个非常有趣的文化时刻，几年前还没有人真正谈论青少年和青年文化，然后到了1957年左右，它就在空气中，每个人都在谈论它。比尔·哈利（Bill Haley）和他的彗星乐队在1956年底出现，人们听说过摇滚乐，听说过猫王，显然周围有更多的钱，人们在谈论咖啡吧，他们在谈论苏豪区是这种趋势的绝对中心，所以苏豪区，没错，“双眼”被一个叫《六五特别节目》（Six Five Special）的BBC节目选中了，所以它是电视节目，它非常时髦，这是一个关于青年文化和流行音乐的开创性节目，BBC实际上接管了“双眼”，并从“双眼”现场直播了《六五特别节目》，
And the DIY, the amateur spirit is the point. So it's people who basically bought cheap guitars, washboards and things like that, and they're playing in their bedrooms as teenagers. So Beatles, Beginners, the Skiffle group. Yeah. So almost a lot of these bands, a lot of the iconic bands of the 60s began
我想这现在一定已经丢失了。这突然把它奉为那个地方。所以这对摔跤手来说是个好消息。对摔跤手来说是个绝妙的消息。绝对精彩的消息。所以死亡博士，他本以为他接手了一家失败的三明治店，突然发现他接手了一个霓虹灯招牌上写着“世界著名的双眼咖啡吧，明星之家”的地方。哇。所以这是你后来得到的那些地方的第一个例子之一，比如洞穴俱乐部（Cavern Club），一个可能相当破败的夜店，基本上变得非常具有象征意义，是的，更广泛的文化，甚至是经济运动的象征。所以你开始得到这些歌手，人们会说，好吧，他们是在“双眼”被发现的。他们在“双眼”演出过。这就是他们的等价物。所以谁是最著名的？所以第一个，可能最重要的是汤米·斯蒂尔（Tommy Steele）。
or as skiffle bands or started out playing skiffle when they were 14 or 15, just sort of playing almost kind of folk blues kind of music, but in a very sort of jaunty, jolly way in their bedrooms on those sort of terrible guitars. So this is what Wally White and the Vipers are doing. And they're very successful in this you start getting cues outside the two eyes by the i think by sort of 1957 or so and then um people start to notice skiffle so 56 57 in britain is a sort of really interesting kind of cultural
哦，是的。所以汤米·斯蒂尔的第一张单曲叫《与穴居人摇滚》（Rock with the Caveman）。他的大热门实际上是《歌唱蓝调》（Singing the Blues），1957年1月。他经常被描述为第一个，也许还有朗尼·多尼根（Lonnie Donegan），但汤米·斯蒂尔是第一个真正的英国流行明星。他19岁。他的青春，他的工人阶级背景，因为他来自伯蒙德赛（Bermondsey），他们是包装的一部分，他被包装成英国的猫王。我认为他也是第一个有尖叫声的英国明星，有女孩尖叫。她们是在“双眼”的地下室里尖叫吗？
moment when a few years before nobody was really talking about teenagers and youth culture and then by 1957 or so it's in the air everybody's talking about it bill haley and his comments have come at the end of 1956 sort of people have heard of rock and roll they've heard of elvis and there's clearly there's more money around and people are talking about coffee bars and they're talking about soho is a kind of absolute center for this and soho exactly and the two eyes is picked up by a bbc program called six five special so it's tv it's very groovy and it's a it's a it's a sort of pioneering um program about youth culture and and pop music and the bbc actually take over the two eyes and do a live six five special from the Two Eyes,
就在几年前，还没人真正谈论青少年和青年文化，但到了1957年左右，这种风气已经弥漫开来，每个人都在谈论它。比尔·哈利和他的彗星乐队在1956年底出现，人们听说过摇滚乐，听说过猫王，显然手头的钱也多了起来。人们开始谈论咖啡吧，谈论苏豪区，认为那里是这一切的绝对中心。没错，正是苏豪区。BBC的一档节目《六五特别节目》看中了“双眼”咖啡吧，这档节目非常时髦，是关于青年文化和流行音乐的先驱性节目。BBC甚至接管了“双眼”咖啡吧，并从那里进行了《六五特别节目》的现场直播。
which I think must now be lost. And that sort of enshrines it suddenly as the place. So this is good news for the wrestlers. Brilliant news for the wrestlers. Absolutely splendid news. So Dr Death, who had thought he was taking over a failing sandwich shop, suddenly finds he's taken over a place which has this neon sign that says, the world famous two eyes
我想那段录像现在肯定已经遗失了。这让它突然间成为了一个标志性的地方。这对摔跤手来说是个好消息。对摔跤手来说真是太棒了。绝对是天大的好消息。所以，“死亡博士”本以为自己接手的是一家快倒闭的三明治店，结果发现自己接手的地方竟然挂着霓虹灯招牌，上面写着“世界闻名的双眼咖啡吧”。
coffee bar the home of the stars wow so it's one of the first examples of those places that you get later on let's say the cavern club of a sort of probably quite down a heel night spot that basically becomes very sort of emblematic yeah the symbol of a wider kind of cultural, indeed, economic kind of movement. So you start getting these singers and people will say, well, they were discovered at the Two Eyes. They played at the Two Eyes. And that's their equivalent of sort of. So who's the most famous? So the first one, probably the most important one is Tommy Steele.
咖啡吧，明星之家。哇，这就像是后来出现的那些地方的早期范例，比如洞穴俱乐部，原本可能只是一个相当破旧的夜店，却基本上成为了某种更广泛的文化乃至经济运动的象征。于是，开始出现一些歌手，人们会说，他们是在“双眼”被发掘的，他们在“双眼”演出过。这相当于他们的某种资历。那么谁最出名呢？第一个，可能也是最重要的一个，是汤米·斯蒂尔。
Oh, yeah. So Tommy Steele's first single was called Rock with the Caveman. And his big hit was actually Singing the Blues, January 1957. He's often described as the first, and maybe Lonnie Donegan, but Tommy Steele is the first true British pop
哦，是的。汤米·斯蒂尔的第一首单曲叫《与穴居人摇滚》，他真正的大热单曲是1957年1月的《歌唱蓝调》。他常被描述为第一位，或许还有朗尼·多尼根，但汤米·斯蒂尔是第一位真正的英国流行音乐明星。
star. He's 19. His youth, his working class because he's from Bermondsey, they are sort of part of the package, and he's packaged as the British Elvis. He's also the first British star, I think, who has screaming, who has girls screaming. And are they screaming in the basement of the Two Eyes?
他当时19岁。他的年轻、他来自伯蒙德赛的工人阶级背景，这些都是他个人形象的一部分，他被包装成“英国猫王”。我认为他也是第一位让女孩们尖叫的英国明星。她们是在“双眼”的地下室里尖叫吗？
They were screaming. Well, I mean, him having been at the Two Eyes, all these people who were at the Two Eyes or weren't, it's sort of shrouded in myth and controversy. So his managers basically, and one of his managers was a guy called Larry Parnes, who was very famous for developing this type of stable in the late 50s. Larry Parnes said, oh, I discovered him singing at the Two Eyes. And that, again, this is probably the first example of that sort of theme
他们当时在尖叫。我的意思是，他曾在Two Eyes演出过，所有那些去过或没去过Two Eyes的人，那里的一切都笼罩在神话和争议之中。所以他的经纪人们，其中一位叫拉里·帕恩斯（Larry Parnes），他以在50年代末培养这种艺人而闻名。拉里·帕恩斯说，哦，我是在Two Eyes发现他唱歌的。这可能又是那种主题的第一个例子，
that you get so often in the 60s, that there's a particular iconic venue and people are discovered there by managers. You know, it's the classic Cavern Club kind of story. And then transformed. And this is what supposedly happens to Tommy Steele. So you say about the names, Marty Wilde, Vince Eager, Tommy Quickly, Duffy Power, Rory Storm, Johnny Gentle, Dickie Pride.
这种主题在60年代非常常见，即有一个标志性的场所，人们在那里被经纪人发掘。你知道，这就是典型的洞穴俱乐部（Cavern Club）式的故事。然后被改造。这就是据说发生在汤米·斯蒂尔（Tommy Steele）身上的事。所以你提到了这些名字，马蒂·怀尔德（Marty Wilde）、文斯·伊格（Vince Eager）、汤米·奎克利（Tommy Quickly）、达菲·鲍尔（Duffy Power）、罗里·斯托姆（Rory Storm）、约翰尼·金特尔（Johnny Gentle）、迪基·普莱德（Dickie Pride）。
There's a point at which you think some of these- I mean, imagine being Johnny Gentle. Well, Dickie Pride. I mean, would Gentle, Dickie Pride. There's a point at which you think some of these... Imagine being Johnny Gentle. Well, Dickie Pride. I mean, would you be Dickie Pride? I think I'd rather be Dickie Pride than Johnny Gentle. Or Duffy Power. Would you be Duffy Power, Tom? Yeah, Duffy Power.
有时候你会觉得其中一些人——我的意思是，想象一下成为约翰尼·金特尔。嗯，迪基·普莱德。我的意思是，金特尔会吗，迪基·普莱德。有时候你会觉得其中一些人……想象一下成为约翰尼·金特尔。嗯，迪基·普莱德。我的意思是，你会愿意成为迪基·普莱德吗？我想我宁愿成为迪基·普莱德而不是约翰尼·金特尔。或者达菲·鲍尔。你会愿意成为达菲·鲍尔吗，汤姆？是的，达菲·鲍尔。
Marty Wilde was the father of Kim Wilde, wasn't he? Yeah, I think he was. And Vince Eager, I think, was quite successful. I don't know about Tommy Quickly. I haven't followed his career. But there are two other singers who are supposedly involved with the Two Eyes. And again, it's one of those stories that you sort of think that they sort of tell in their autobiographies, but the autobiography is a ghost written. So you don't know whether it's a bit like kind of
马蒂·怀尔德是金·怀尔德（Kim Wilde）的父亲，对吧？是的，我想他是。而文斯·伊格，我想，相当成功。我不知道汤米·奎克利的情况。我没有关注过他的职业生涯。但还有另外两位歌手据说也与Two Eyes有关。这又是那种你觉得他们会在自传中讲述的故事，但自传是代笔写的。所以你不知道这是否有点像
Suetonius and his Lives of Roman Emperors. You don't know whether it's part of the formula. Is it just part of the formula and and especially in these cases they themselves probably just end up believing what's written in their autobiography because they can't remember whether they were there or not so the first example of a famous one are you familiar with the career of terry nellums so terry nellums is a messenger boy from acton and he plays in a teenage skiffle band. So in other words, he's heard blues music and stuff like that, picks up a guitar, plays with his mates,
苏埃托尼乌斯的《罗马十二帝王传》。你不知道这是否只是公式的一部分。这是否只是公式的一部分，特别是在这些案例中，他们自己可能最终也相信了自传里写的东西，因为他们记不清自己是否真的去过那里。所以第一个著名的例子，你熟悉特里·内勒姆斯（Terry Nellums）的职业生涯吗？特里·内勒姆斯是来自阿克顿（Acton）的一名送信员，他在一个青少年噪音爵士乐（skiffle）乐队里演奏。换句话说，他听过蓝调音乐之类的东西，拿起吉他，和伙伴们一起演奏，
has a little stint at the Two Eyes, and he's filmed there by Six Five Special, the cameras. And he is seen by a TV producer called Jack Good. And Paul, our producer, definitely knows who Terry Lellums is. Well, he's given away his real identity. He's given away the real name. Well, he's not his real identity. He's given away his stage name. Because Jack Good says,
在Two Eyes待过一小段时间，然后被《Six Five Special》节目的摄像机拍了下来。他被一位名叫杰克·古德（Jack Good）的电视制片人看到了。保罗，我们的制片人，肯定知道特里·内勒姆斯是谁。嗯，他泄露了他的真实身份。他泄露了真实姓名。嗯，那不是他的真实身份。他泄露了他的艺名。因为杰克·古德说，
you can't be a success if you're called Terry Lellums. You should call yourself Adam Faith. So he becomes Adam Faith, and Adam Faith is one of the... He's one of the... I guess our younger listeners probably won't even have heard of him. He's one of the absolute sort of outstanding British rock and roll singers of the very late 50s, very early 60s. So pre the Beatles, selling tens of thousands of copies of their records a day.
如果你叫特里·内勒姆斯，你不可能成功。你应该叫自己亚当·菲斯（Adam Faith）。于是他成了亚当·菲斯，而亚当·菲斯是……他是……我想我们年轻的听众可能都没听说过他。他是50年代末到60年代初最杰出的英国摇滚歌手之一。在披头士乐队之前，他的唱片每天能卖出几万张。
Number one in Christmas 1959. And his single, What Do You Want, his most famous single, was produced by John Barry of the Bond film. So another kind of great 60s name. So that's Adam Faith. The sense that the 60s is incubating here. Exactly. The Two Eyes is the place.
1959年圣诞节排名第一。他的单曲《What Do You Want》，他最著名的单曲，是由邦德电影的约翰·巴里（John Barry）制作的。所以这是另一个伟大的60年代名字。这就是亚当·菲斯。那种60年代正在这里孕育的感觉。没错。Two Eyes就是那个地方。
And the other person, Tom, now, are you familiar with the musical career of Harry Webb? Is that Cliff Richard? It is Cliff Richard. Because he was the only one you hadn't mentioned. I mean, he's still around, isn't he? He was on the Queen's bus in the Platinum Jubilee Parade, I think. He was.
还有另一个人，汤姆，现在，你熟悉哈里·韦伯（Harry Webb）的音乐生涯吗？那是克里夫·理查德（Cliff Richard）吗？正是克里夫·理查德。因为他是你还没提到的那一个。我的意思是，他现在还在活跃，不是吗？我想他在白金禧年游行的女王巴士上。他确实在。
He was. He's been uncancelled, hasn't he? Yes. He went through a bit of a dip a few years ago. He's been in every Jubilee celebration, and he's had a hit in every decade since the 50s. It's very impressive. Yeah.
他确实在。他已经被“解封”了，不是吗？是的。几年前他经历了一段低谷。他参加了每一次禧年庆典，并且自50年代以来，每个十年都有热门歌曲。这非常令人印象深刻。是的。
Peter Pan of pop peter pan of pop yeah so he had a booking at the two eyes in the summer of 1958 and again that becomes part of his kind of as it were his legend in the late 50s and then he gets his deal with emi and uh on it off he goes um his band was renamed from the drifters to the Shadows, and they become very successful. The rest is history. The rest is history, Tom. So The Two Eyes has this moment, really, as the sort of the basement where you go to hear Skiffle. Between about 1957 and probably 1959.
流行音乐的彼得·潘，流行音乐的彼得·潘，是的。所以他在1958年夏天在Two Eyes有一次预订演出，这又成为了他在50年代末传奇的一部分，然后他与EMI签了约，他就出发了。他的乐队从“漂流者”（The Drifters）更名为“影子乐队”（The Shadows），他们变得非常成功。剩下的就是历史了。剩下的就是历史了，汤姆。所以Two Eyes确实有这样一个时刻，作为你听噪音爵士乐的地下室。大约在1957年到1959年之间。
Does the ceiling drip with sweat? I'm sure it does. And it echoes to the screams of the teenage fans. I think it's probably also a very good example of that place that basically, by the time you've heard of it, it's over. Yeah, it's cool.
天花板会滴汗吗？我肯定会。那里回荡着青少年粉丝的尖叫声。我认为这可能也是一个很好的例子，说明那个地方基本上当你听说它的时候，它就已经结束了。是的，这很酷。
Its moment has gone. So like the Cavern, like Carnaby Street, like all those sort of iconic places that were produced in the youth culture boom of the late 50s and 60s. So basically what happens to the Two Eyes? It's obviously uncool by the time the Beatles
它的时刻已经过去了。就像洞穴俱乐部，就像卡纳比街，就像所有那些在50年代末和60年代青年文化繁荣时期产生的标志性场所一样。所以Two Eyes基本上发生了什么？当披头士乐队
become well known, 1962-63 because skiffle is no longer the thing. It's become proper rock and roll and pop music and rock music as it divides later in the 60s. The Two Eyes closes in 1970, so that's the end of it. And Two Eyes closes in 1970,
变得家喻户晓时，即1962-63年，它显然已经不酷了，因为噪音爵士乐不再流行了。它变成了真正的摇滚乐和流行音乐，以及后来60年代分裂出来的摇滚乐。Two Eyes在1970年关闭，所以这就是它的终点。Two Eyes在1970年关闭，
so that's the end of it. And if you go there now, do you know what you'll find? It's all Compton Street, so yes. It's actually fish and chips. So it's a fish and chip shop. So basically what you should do is do a walk to Barking Abbey, but see if you can take it
所以这就是它的终点。如果你现在去那里，你知道你会发现什么吗？那是康普顿街（Compton Street），所以是的。它实际上是炸鱼薯条店。所以它是一家炸鱼薯条店。所以你基本上应该做的是去巴金修道院（Barking Abbey）走走，但看看你能不能
on Compton Street and reward yourself with some fish and chips. Well, as you said, I mean, that's pretty much the opposite of Barking Abbey. So I think it's a great tribute to this episode that we've managed to get two such different places in. Top nuns and Cliff Richard.
在康普顿街走走，并用一些炸鱼薯条奖励自己。嗯，正如你所说，我的意思是，那几乎与巴金修道院完全相反。所以我认为我们能把这两个如此不同的地方结合在一起，是对这一集最好的致敬。顶级修女和克里夫·理查德。
Top nuns and Cliff Richard, yeah. Brilliant. Okay, well, fabulous. So we will be back tomorrow with two top Londoners. Top Londoners? Who are we going to choose? Who are we going to choose? Who are we going to choose? Very exciting.
顶级修女和克里夫·理查德，是的。太棒了。好的，太棒了。所以我们明天会带着两位顶级伦敦人回来。顶级伦敦人？我们要选谁？我们要选谁？我们要选谁？非常令人兴奋。
So tune in tomorrow and find out. We will see you then. Bye-bye. Bye. Bye. Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. I'm Marina Hyde.
所以明天收听节目找出答案吧。我们到时候见。再见。再见。感谢收听《历史的余味》（The Rest Is History）。如需收听额外剧集、抢先收听、无广告收听以及加入我们的聊天社区，请在restishistorypod.com注册。网址是restishistorypod.com。我是玛丽娜·海德（Marina Hyde）。
And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip, and on our Q&A we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我是理查德·奥斯曼（Richard Osman）。我们共同主持《娱乐的余味》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。这是你每周获取娱乐新闻、评论、一点点演艺圈八卦的地方，在我们的问答环节中，我们将揭开娱乐业的幕布，告诉你它是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、额外剧集和抢先购买现场演出门票，请前往therestisentertainment.com。网址是therestisentertainment.com。这一集还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。